[Music]
foreign
hey you guys what's going on it's Sunday
I don't know how many people are in
there I can't really see it at the
moment yeah there's about 10. okay so
we're talking to somebody for a second I
don't know I had this weird thing but I
was like talking to nobody
all right today's about sicario all
right yeah you can show Jenny right
there it's a really nice steel book uh
Louis sent that to me Hernandez it's uh
got a clear plastic protective case that
goes over the steel book it's just a
really that's a great cover actually
yeah it's a really nice steelbook and
this is a um this is a great movie Jenny
had never seen it this is my second time
seeing it yeah Jenny liked it uh yeah I
thought it was great but it's um
oh
it's the same director that did uh the
new Blade Runner movie and the Dune
movies it's got a [ __ ] awesome score
he also made enemy which uh which I
really liked actually I don't remember
Jake Gyllenhaal that's a I I don't
remember if you watched that with me or
not okay but I really like that movie
this movie here man what's what's good
about it is that it's accurate all right
it's accurate for
Special Operations and uh kind of joint
or combined Department
Special Operations law enforcement type
[ __ ] happening on the border against
those Mexican cartels and Central
American cartels are involved in it too
outside of Mexico some of them in South
America I think I think Colombia is
mentioned
uh some guys that were involved in that
are in this movie
um Delta Force agents are in it uh one
of the characters a guy with glass is
kind of birth control glasses they're
like these that I have
uh he's in I don't remember what that
character's name is yeah he's only in a
few scenes yeah but
um a Delta Force guy
named uh Larry Vickers who has his own
channels you can see you just look up
Larry Vickers I remember he reviewed
this movie and he said that guy is based
on somebody he knows
that that's a real Delta uh agent people
use the word operative a lot I'm [ __ ]
so sick of that they'll just say
anybody's an operator or not but that's
generic [ __ ] do you ask me guys from
sfod or the unit they're they're more
like agents in this role so better to
call those guys agents instead of
operators and and [ __ ] special
operatives it's just so [ __ ] corny
and then
kind of what the movie gets into is that
if you start going into weird kind of um
government service DOD which is
Department of Defense or any kind of
like
the Contracting world that supports law
enforcement military which I was
involved in that in weird ways a lot of
the stuff that you do you don't know
what it is that you're doing you don't
ask any damn questions you just do what
you're told
they're not telling you for a reason
they're just saying go here we're going
to do this and then you're coming back
and it's usually just support and help
in the case I was in
classroom type stuff helping out
training people
um packing up crates and shipping them
out
getting things ready to ship out to
airfields and you just they don't give
you any details all right for a lot of
different reasons the dudes that are
telling you to do this they don't know a
lot of times
and a lot of times that's protection
you know they don't tell you because
you you can't tell anybody anything so
if you ever got captured or anything
like that
they could torture you all day long you
couldn't answer any questions and that
kind of protects other people that's an
extreme situation but mostly it has to
do with legal stuff you know it's why
they don't tell you because what you're
doing is
technically not legal maybe well that's
kind of what this movie yeah that's what
this movie is all about sure you're
skirting laws and skirting rules and
you're doing that on purpose and you're
being told to and everybody knows and
that's part of the game
and it's getting other countries
involved in [ __ ] that you're doing so
they can do certain things you can't and
it all has to do with skirting rules and
laws but you're but the thing is is that
you're complying with the law that's all
it is complying with laws and
regulations
so how do you get the job done while
still complying and this is [ __ ]
that's what this movie's about
they're trying to
[ __ ] up cartels and send assassins at
them and [ __ ] but they can't do that so
they have to use other people to do that
and it's a great movie great movie yeah
everything is just like loopholes I mean
and that's the thing about uh Emily
Blunt's character in this who she's
mostly just brought on as well they
don't tell her at first they don't
really tell her much of anything for
that very reason but you know it turns
out if you haven't seen this movie that
pretty much the only reason they brought
her along was they had to to kind of
cover their ass because they're like
well they're doing like some CIA [ __ ]
and it's like we can't really do this
stuff in another country like or we
can't do stuff within the US like
without FBI things so they had they had
to get like her sign off on [ __ ] they
needed Witnesses from around the
department that's all it was but that
department was not in charge it had no
say-so so they were kind of dead weight
that's all they were they were just
there to be on paperwork yeah they
didn't need them at all and when you see
the movie they don't need her and her a
partner they're a detriment and then at
the end of the movie man [ __ ] they
make her sign a piece of paper if not
they're gonna she's gonna commit suicide
that that's what they said and an
American didn't tell her to do that
another dude from another country
Colombia told her to do that
and he was
that way everything was deniable it you
know I mean it was a foreigner that was
telling her to do that 410 yeah I mean
everything they had worked everything
out right you know what I mean and she
was just kind of like I mean she's
almost like a patsy really I mean like
she didn't know that at the beginning
like they kind of get her in on it
because you know she's FBI she's
actually not really to do with the drug
cartel directly she's more she's like on
the kidnapping unit right
um but then like that that horrifying uh
you know thing at the beginning which is
in the U.S it's in Arizona and they find
like all those bodies in the wall of
that guy that's like on the cartel and
everything and so she kind of gets
pissed off about that and then there's a
bomb and it blows up like some of her
team and [ __ ] like that so that's how
like these these other kind of guys get
in they're like we want to get back at
the guys who did that or who are like
the bosses of the guys who did that so
that's kind of how they talk her into it
because she kind of wants to see them
get caught too only problem is that
she's kind of coming at it with the
understanding that they're gonna do it
like in like buy the book and in the way
you're supposed to and they absolutely
have no intention of doing that that was
from the very beginning when the
higher-ups are talking about who they're
gonna send
to to at who who are they going to ask
to volunteer for this and [ __ ] anybody
that had a legal background anybody who
had studied law and University no no
lawyers yeah because her partner is
played by Daniel Kalua from uh probably
I knew him from get out he was in Black
Panther and stuff too but um but yeah
because he had gone to law school uh
they were like no they could like kind
of use them like to kind of drive people
around but that was about it they
couldn't tell him and uh trying to think
what else they yeah they show extensive
use of
cops
SF guys
foreigners criminals
uh anything they can
even even uh bad cops
they'll use anything because it it's a
it's a special operation and a lot of
times a special operation is
really
really a special operation a lot of
times means a covert operation and a lot
of times it's covert because it's black
and a lot of times it's black because
it's illegal all right they're not
supposed to be doing it and if you get
caught you're going to be denied they
say we don't do that dude
you know yeah there's there's and
there's this so you're on your own
you're on that team but I mean they pick
a fight in public to shoot up a bunch of
guys to make a cartel mad in public and
yeah like right on the border like in a
traffic jam in a traffic jam and and she
was like you know she was like well this
was wrong and they were like [ __ ] it
well like all the civilians and stuff
yeah she's like normally if you were
doing [ __ ] by the book obviously you
wouldn't do that because there's too
many civilians yeah but they wanted to
shake up the tree and find out who was
moving and who was where and uh
and they got a dude Del Toro plays this
guy you don't really know who what he is
who he is she keeps asking him too many
[ __ ] questions all right and he's not
answering really
she doesn't get a hint she that's the
thing about this character is that she
does not take a hint very well but I
guess they're doing it for the for the
uh
uh maybe she's pathological
pathologically has to know things and
can't work in the dark because they make
fun of her for not being able to work in
the dark well wasn't her they made it
was the other guy her partner he says
just don't keep us in the dark as though
you're scared of the dark yeah and
because they're all working in the dark
nobody knows everything about every
little aspect they're just well like I
said you you know those two characters
they just brought them on like you said
for kind of like legal reasons they
don't really need them and they just
kind of like you know sideline them at
every opportunity they just kind of have
to have them there for paperwork
purposes so they're just you know
they're on a need to know basis and they
mostly don't need to know anything yeah
but they're kind of like hey we thought
this was like on the team and we're
doing the operation and like we'd kind
of like to know what we're doing and
what we're getting in for but
when you start off in a combat arms unit
when you're young and a lot of these
that's where a lot of these guys come
from infantry Airborne Ranger SF working
in the dark or being lied to is just a
standard part of the job job you you
understand that they that your chain of
command is lying to you
they have to because okay here here's
here's how I'm gonna give you a good
example of how [ __ ] was done by dudes
that I [ __ ] served with
operation
just cause that was the invasion of
Panama
those dudes kept getting the guys that
were tasked to to do the Panama invasion
for three or four weeks kept getting
sent out on these field problems that
involved specific
Road intersections with a building here
and this and that and over and over
again they just did this same
dumb [ __ ] mission
and then one day they got alerted and
got sent down to the Airfield and when
they got to the Airfield once they were
flying they handed them that same map
that they normally trained them on for
that Road intersection and this and that
and then all of a sudden things were
relabeled like this building is a bank
and this is over here and this is there
and then right before landing they
[ __ ] handed out another map to all
the [ __ ] Squad leaders and everything
showing the names of the roads and they
realized that
they had been training all that time to
take out specific targets inside of
Panama they were lied to the whole time
about what what it was that they were
doing and they didn't know until hours
before touching down because there was
no telephones there was no way they
could call Mom I'm going to Panama next
week you know what I mean because that's
what they would do
we're gonna go invade this thing it
would have leaked
which would have jeopardized everything
well that's what these guys are doing
but it's even [ __ ] tighter
because the [ __ ] they're doing is all
[ __ ] sideways and wonky and involved
in a bunch of different countries none
of those guys knows everything
they only just they're just going hey
look do this okay there's no questions
see there you have to work in the dark
and that's what they were talking about
she just kept asking questions
she kept asking this one dude basically
trying to figure out what he was and you
never really do kind of figure out what
he was he was some kind of lawyer but he
had training like a Delta level trading
and he was in that unit so I guess they
trained him
but he was Colombian
so therefore he was not an American
citizen
he was some kind of an advisor
but they used him as an assassin that
way if he ever got caught they could say
we don't know that dude
he's not with us
he's Colombian
yeah that's
yeah I mean she asks him at one point
when they're on the plane because they
first tell her oh we're going to El Paso
or he says El Paso area and then they
end up going to Juarez and uh so
basically she asked him on the plane
she's like you know where are you from
or what do you do or whatever and all he
says is I go where I'm sent yeah that's
all he says yep can we talk about like
Benicio del Toro I've always really
liked him as an actor and um he's great
in this he actually got
um nominated for a bafta for this movie
I don't think he won but uh yeah he got
nominated for this and I think that he
got um you know uh picked out a lot by
like critics like saying how good his
performance was but yeah he's great at
this the the guy that wrote this
I didn't even realize Taylor Sheridan
was the same guy that wrote remember uh
hell or high water and Wind River we did
both of those like this because I guess
this is like the third movie and the of
you know the modern Western drug war
type of thing and uh yeah so it's the
same screenwriter as those and like I
said somebody they've been talking about
the cinematography yeah Roger deakins
did this who actually did uh Blade
Runner 2049 he did Skyfall uh he did
Fargo he works with the Coen Brothers a
lot but yeah I mean the this is a
beautiful looking movie and the score is
amazing now the guy that did it uh Johan
Johansson was an Icelandic guys
unfortunately he passed away a few years
ago and I was sitting there going I
think he had done another one of the
knee villeneuve's movies before maybe it
was Prisoners I can't really remember
but I knew that music sounded familiar
he did the music for Mandy okay that's
the same guy yeah that's what I was like
I knew that name looked familiar earlier
yeah it's got a great uh score yeah I
think the score might have been
nominated for an Oscar actually it was
yeah now I've seen the uh I've seen the
sequel to this and it's actually even
better than this one is one of the few
times where it's they're making a third
one too yeah the sequel's even better so
uh as far as I'll show that to Jenny you
know we'll run that one too
but uh yeah
yeah they're making a third one called
sicario capos yeah in development okay
as far as I know but yeah it's good
it just kind of shows the kind of the
the gray nature
of a lot of that stuff I mean you know
they were gonna they were gonna kill her
if she [ __ ] ratted them out about
what they were doing yeah you know well
clearly she wasn't she didn't really cut
out well like I said she works for the
FBI and she didn't have anything to do
with the drug cartels really I mean they
just kind of like brought her on because
she had kind of something to do with one
case like in particular but she had
never worked like across the border she
didn't do any of that kind of stuff
especially what they're doing is they're
using a bunch of damn law enforcement
different kind of law enforcement
agencies
with DOD agencies
and and and Special Forces which would
be Delta or sfod depending on what you
want to call them certain guys from
Delta
and they're like four or five at a time
if they needed guys that were really
good shooters
when this is a law enforcement Mission
but they're conducting basically raids
with military style raids something like
kind of out of had a James Bond
partially
so then it's happening
coming from like at the presidential
level
okay it's like the president asking for
this not bureaucrats
so that kind of changes the game you
know what I mean it was definitely
higher up they were saying that this
wasn't a this isn't appointed officials
behind all this these are elected
officials that are Behind These
operations so you have to do them
basically and they just have to recruit
the right kind of people that they can
trust
now a long time ago
when Special Forces got involved
with uh all the weird cocaine action and
the Iran Contra scandal a lot of stuff
in the intelligence Community like CIA
which there were some CIA people
involved in this too or possibly Seattle
yeah yeah the one did did eventually say
that it was the Central Intelligence
that wasn't that that's who he worked
for
but um
remember that this is even back in the
80s people were absolutely kind of like
horrified that
intelligence agencies hired criminals
and they were like well we have in this
business we have to work with bad people
sometimes
you know and the the American public
didn't couldn't really accept it so that
[ __ ] started to go deeper and deeper
underground you know in the 80s because
the American civilians don't really kind
of have the maturity to understand the
re the realism of doing these kind of
operations they want them done that's
the way they're voting but they don't
understand the nuts and bolts have
actually making something like that
happen and this movie shows
the nuts and bolts of how these kind of
things happen how they do them
now the glamor says you think
yeah it's not very glamorous at all no
and very uh very [ __ ] uh down to
earth and gritty and uh a lot of
psychology behind it and a lot of
loyalty those guys from those units are
[ __ ] loyal to each other and and the
unit they're not really loyal to
Concepts like [ __ ] law and you know
what I mean in the legal system or
anything
and if the mission was compromised that
you would commit suicide that that was
what they say in the end you're just
committing suicide and they literally
mean that they're gonna pop you and
[ __ ] make it look like you committed
suicide and they run those agencies so
there's not going to be any deep
investigation into the suicide they they
can just do the paperwork to get that
[ __ ] right through the system
yeah
I was reading a review of this that I
thought said a very interesting thing
they said this movie is actually like uh
analogous too they said you know how
Apocalypse Now was like about the
Vietnam War this is like the Apocalypse
Now of the drug war
um yeah so I saw like a bunch of ones
and it is kind of like that because it's
kind of like a a journey into the Heart
of Darkness type of thing where
um Denny Villeneuve I think he even said
that uh you know the the illegal you
know drugs being illegal and stuff like
that has caused this war that we've now
got to a position where we have to
become the very monsters we're fighting
in order to you know get any play on it
and I think like that's kind of the
thing about her character is that she
just keeps getting like Sidelines she's
just so defeated by the end because
there's like nothing she can do she's
just one person and there's like no
you know the way that we the way that
it's set up now it's just like there's
no way that anybody that's like on the
right side of anything is just gonna be
able to like fix it you know what I mean
because it's so [ __ ] up and it's
totally correct it's it's totally stupid
it is yeah the the idea of the drug war
was to make big money and make huge
government agencies you can make a [ __ ]
ton of money and then
Wiki and then people who can get in
there and play Both Sides that's going
on too corruption on both sides and uh
which is also shown in this movie
because you also I mean like John
bernthal's character yep who's a cop in
Phoenix right he's like a phoenix cop
and he's also playing both sides with
that kind of [ __ ] like he's great in
this too he's only like in one one or
two scenes but he's great in it yeah so
now cops and soldiers and [ __ ] like that
they can all make money off of off of
fighting this drug war and then it can
go up and up into the higher strata and
then at the political level you know
what I mean you can have the CIA
actually like they did in the 80s with
the Iran country Scandal buy cocaine and
sell that and then from the proceeds buy
Stinger missiles to help their [ __ ]
Afghans fight the Soviets there's all
kinds of weird [ __ ] that they do and
they still do it they have to be
so
yeah
dumb idea what would be a lot safer
smarter
wouldn't make as much money but it would
be smarter to legalize all that [ __ ] in
control it the same way you do alcohol
and all the money would just evaporate
from that the prices would go way down
the drug cartels would vanish because
there's no real profit in it and then
and but and then and then like he would
the thing is is then the law enforcement
would miss out on a lot of money because
their budgets would shrink and that's
why they don't want to do it
you know there's a whole
system there that is old now that's kind
of ossified its whole purpose is to
[ __ ] get Federal funding to fight
drugs and if that [ __ ] drug war
vanishes that whole [ __ ] fact faction
of the government advantages and what
are they going to do they got houses to
buy and [ __ ] swimming pools to pay
for and [ __ ] you know
it's just that same old [ __ ] scam
overpower
and weed yeah and uh people that want to
get high
and then they uh make it real it ends up
being real valuable and they kill each
other over
and a lot of them dying in [ __ ]
Mexico and Central and South America
they're killing each other over there
down there over it
and then elected elected leaders in
Central America
hire the cartels to help them get into
office and just all kinds of [ __ ]
happens it's far dirtier than you think
those cartels and some of them are
basically just basically arms of the
[ __ ] governments down there
so that's like their version of Special
Forces some of those Narco armies are
[ __ ] do you looked at it you can look
to see videos on them man they got
[ __ ] armored personnel carriers and
jeeps and uniforms and top-notch weapons
they got a [ __ ] ton of money and you're
talking about like there's thousands of
them it's not a little banned up and
it's thousands of them in uniform
and they're all cops and soldiers and
[ __ ] they're not just scub bags
they actually come from
they come out of the army and they want
a good job they go work for those guys
Zach said I preferred this to the sequel
because the sequel felt like a kind of
generic action movie to me compared to
this one which is more an eerie
political thriller I remember liking the
sequel more but we'll see yeah I haven't
seen the sequel yet so I can't speak to
it I thought this was fantastic I
thought it was like really really good
well and like I said I'm not the only
person because it got nominated for a
[ __ ] ton of oscars and most of the
critics that year said it was like one
of the best movies of the year and [ __ ]
like that Zach said one of my favorite
Parts is the scene of Benicio and Emily
arguing from far away oh yeah I remember
what you talked about uh Roger deakins
wanted to shoot close-ups of their faces
but Denise like no the single take long
shot as it was yeah that was actually
like a really good I mean the
cinematography in this is so so gorgeous
I really really liked all of the
especially all the night shots where
they did kind of like the the night
vision and then like uh you know just
the sunset like over the desert and
stuff like that like those [ __ ] great
vistas of the desert and everything like
that
um
so okay discuss the mayor of Juarez when
this movie came out like or shortly
before this movie came out uh he told
people in Mexico to not go see the movie
because it uh demonized or presented
like a false and negative uh thing of
the movie he's saying yeah the movie The
or the city used to be like that like
back in you know 2010 something like
that but it's not really like that
anymore uh I don't really know because
I've never been there but
I don't I don't really know like because
I mean the way they showed in the movie
yeah it's pretty [ __ ] up but with the
especially that shot with like all the
bodies hanging from the bridge like with
the heads cut off and everything like
that so you also told them don't watch a
Rambo last blood
remember Rambo was fighting the cartels
oh yeah that's right I forgot who he was
fighting all I just remember was like
he's fighting I forgot who he was
fighting all I remembered was just like
ooh Gore you know what I mean cut that
dude's head off that's right yeah he's
fighting cartels that's yeah that's
right no I'm thinking okay I'm thinking
of the other one I'm getting them all
confused yeah which one that was the one
we saw in the theater right yeah okay
okay yeah I think it's called last blood
see I don't even remember what it's
called I think it's what it's called
second to last blood and ultimate blood
that's it they should have called it
Danny Rowling said rainbow last blood
was a slasher flick okay see maybe it is
the one that I'm thinking of yeah
well what was the one that was just in
the theater then Rambo last Blood oh
okay don't you remember
I get them all confused he had that
adopted daughter who was no I remember
the movie I just don't remember if it
was called that you know what I mean
last Blood okay yeah maybe yeah the one
before that was uh Fight Continues and
that's where he was in Myanmar
that's when he was shooting those dudes
up with the machine that was the one I
was thinking of when I said what I said
like about the gore and stuff like that
yeah yeah that was that was the one but
there was a lot of Gore in in last blood
too he cut that dude's head off in the
hotel yeah that's right I remember that
night but the one I was thinking of was
the one before that yeah and then uh
Rambo's Farm on the border down there
was all undermined with [ __ ] tunnels
and [ __ ]
never yeah and he suckered him down in
there and killed him in the tunnels
he lived but he was shot up
yeah
I didn't remember what happened at the
end he just it ends with him just on a
porch all shout out I don't know if he
dies or lifts he may have died but it
was yeah in his lips trying kind of
vague
I like that movie but I don't remember
what happened at the end yeah Zach says
funny enough the same year as this
Specter came out and they had to make
Mexico look like a fantasy with that Day
of the Dead parade to secure funding to
shoot there so I guess it evened out but
yeah it's I don't know I don't know if
Juarez is still like as
uh terrifying as it looks in this movie
but
yeah I'll be remembering that [ __ ]
those bodies hanging from the [ __ ]
bridge for like a really long time they
did that but I don't think they did that
in Juarez they uh there was one little
town that got this is years back I guess
it'd be about 20 years now 15 years
wiped out a whole town and they hung
them from the bottom of a bridge a
couple hundred of them about a hundred I
think that's probably where they got the
idea yeah like for this shot yeah it was
a small town but I think they killed
everybody yikes yeah yeah that's the
thing I mean the wrong people
I don't know I just I really really like
this this is actually one of and I was
like reading some other comments about
um I read like a review and then there's
a bunch of comments like when it first
came out like in the theater and a lot
of people were talking about uh when
they went to see it in the movie theater
like it was one of the tensest movies
that they'd ever watched which it
actually really really is I think it's
it's uh I don't know like the way that
it's shot
is just really kind of I was I don't
know I was just kind of like leaning
forward like that like the whole time
like watching it because you never know
like some really bad [ __ ] up [ __ ] was
gonna happen
um he's talking about oh Zach also says
by the way Roger deakins and his wife
he's the cinematographer on this uh
started doing their podcast again and
they interviewed the photographer of the
film's visual style was based off off of
it's called team deacons by the way it's
fascinating show yeah I mean uh I think
this got an Oscar nomination for best
cinematography too because I mean Roger
deakins he's done I thought he had done
more of the James Bond movies I know he
did Skyfall but I thought he'd done a
few other ones too but I know he works a
lot with the Coen brothers because for
sure he did Fargo I remember that but
yeah he's done he's probably like the
best cinematographer like working today
and you can really see it in this it
looks gorgeous it's a strong movie yeah
and you can totally tell that it's the
same director as dune and Blade Runner
2049 and stuff like that I mean it's
just he has that like dennyville villain
who has such like a uh like a
distinctive style I can't really put my
finger on what it is I would say it's
kind of like an Apocalypse Now a law
enforcement version of Apocalypse Now
yeah I've seen several reviews like make
back comparison like it is very very
much like that kind of story yeah
because yeah like I said you're having
somebody like Emily Blunt's character
who's supposed to be like the
representation of like the Civilized
world and Law and Order and stuff like
that and then just getting more and more
defeated by how [ __ ] morally gray
everything gets like as you're going
like through there at the end like a
descent into madness and evil yeah that
Colombian assassin tells her at the end
he goes move to a small town you know he
says uh you know Doug come here where
the wolves have taken over or something
like that nobody said yeah something
like that because you can't run with
wolves because you need to move to a
small town where there's Law and Order
like it used to be because the rest of
the world's not like that now
yeah I think I think all of it is not
like that Danny rolling said Tom do you
think Emily Blunt's character should
have lived or died and why
uh well in reality she should have died
um but uh they let her live because she
I get I think she's kind of the stand-in
for the audience and kind of like the
narrator in a certain way of the story
but uh
no I think if I was Benicio del Toro if
I was that assassin character would have
killed her because I don't think you
could trust her you couldn't let her go
I kind of feel like in real life
probably they would have killed her
especially because she just threatened
to tell that's enough right I kind of
feel like they probably would have yeah
but they would have killed her and they
made it look like suicide which is what
they were gonna do but I guess they
figured maybe she was like so [ __ ] up
by the experience that just I don't know
maybe she wasn't they weren't a Believer
so maybe they were like maybe they
already had some kind of plan in place
for like if she starts blabbing we
already have like a bunch of other
[ __ ] [ __ ] we can like I don't think
they would have [ __ ] wanted the
complication they'd be afraid that she
would go to the news or something or say
something although they kind of control
the news they can keep that out of the
out of they could keep that out of
corporate news
um but what they because that's why it's
not in there you'll never see it in
there they can keep it out they're
afraid to say that because they're
afraid to print that kind of [ __ ] but
she might show up on a podcast or
something
uh so although I'm not sure a podcast
existed in the time yeah they probably
existed in the time the movie has taken
place what year was it supposed to be
taking place 2010 or something well the
movie came out in 2015 so I'm assuming
it was supposed to be around that time
around that time 2014 yeah 15. so she
could have done some stuff online that
they would have killed her
I kind of yeah and I mean like I said
that's not that's not a ding on the
movie I'm just saying like in real life
they probably would have killed her
that's what I was thinking especially I
mean because I mean she probably should
have kept her mouth shut but you know
yeah dumb dumb but like I said that was
kind of the whole point is that she was
still operating under the assumption
that there were like laws and things
that would you know think protect her
things that they had to like you know
adhere to but they absolutely did not
not so much in that world
you know
no
that uh that one guy with the glasses
that that uh what was his that Larry
Vickers said he was based on a real guy
Jenny didn't see any mention of him but
you guys I mean at least not on the
Wikipedia page or in any of those rooms
I think it's called Vickers Tactical
he um and Larry talks about sicario he
goes through some of the gunfights and
what was correct he said it's a good
movie
um he did point that one guy out with
glasses it's like one of the bit part
characters and he he uh says that that
is based on a real guy and I think they
even used that guy's name
I think but it's in a fictionalized
setting that's if if I remember if
memory serves
but Vickers knew the guy I think he's
kind of like a legendary
kind of a Delta agent
who's talks about some things
evidently yeah he wasn't in I mean he
was in the beginning a little bit
because he was kind of telling everybody
it almost seemed like he was kind of the
higher up guy that was telling everybody
all the [ __ ] like at the beginning but
then like he didn't really see him much
like the end of the movie like it kind
of went more in the direction of Josh
Brolin's game she told she told him I'm
gonna tell and he goes what did he say
he says oh that that's a very bad idea I
think that's what he tried it's kind of
boys I think yeah that would be a big
mistake yeah so that would be a big
mistake that'd be a very big mistake and
[ __ ] you know
I don't know why she could read in
between the lines
but I think that was just the nature of
that character they wanted her to appear
just kind of innocent yeah innocent to
what was really going on Zach says uh
Denise Villeneuve has really usurped
Christopher Nolan as the awesome
director everyone should be obsessed
with for me I like Nolan's older movies
but he's kind of got too far up his own
ass and trying to compete with himself
on a stiff stuff yeah I mean every I
haven't seen all of uh Denise villeneu's
films but all the ones I've seen have
been amazing the um I haven't seen
prisoners from 2013 which you know if
anybody's seen that and would recommend
it let me know but I loved enemy I
thought that you watched that with me
what what is that about Jake Gyllenhaal
was in it and it was like a guy and he
basically like met his doppelganger
do you remember that no and then like at
the end he opened the door and there was
like the big like tarantula hmm I don't
know you don't remember that maybe he
didn't watch it with me I loved that
movie I thought it was like so [ __ ]
it was so [ __ ] weird I was really
into it and it didn't sound familiar but
um yeah maybe yeah maybe I was watching
it in the room and you were doing
something else I don't really know but
uh but yeah I really really liked it but
yeah I mean [ __ ] Blade Runner 2049
was amazing that was a masterpiece Dune
was amazing and this one was amazing
yeah so yeah you know
um he didn't actually do the sequel
because I think he they asked him but he
wasn't available like he was working on
something else
uh Zach said prisoners is so good that's
my favorite movie of his okay well I'll
definitely have to watch that then Danny
Rowling said the sequels action scenes
to this are far superior than this film
just saying okay well we'll watch the
sequel too I remember liking the seek
because well you have the sequel yeah I
thought you did so and I haven't seen it
but this was the first time that I'd
seen this and I thought it was [ __ ]
great yeah it is more of an action flick
yeah you know we'll see yeah so maybe I
don't know like I liked this one because
yeah there was action in it but this one
like he said it was more like a tense
kind of Thriller type of situation and I
maybe like that another one that I have
is that I had I have all the um what
what is it what's the ones called
it's one with all the old mercenaries
the the uh the examples yeah have all
the Expendables too but I haven't done
any reviews on them and a lot of people
didn't like Expendables 3.
but I have the the uh
my Blu-ray has the extended director's
cut or the director's cut in it and the
director's because far superior
to the theatrical cut the directions
Cut's really good and it's because they
they could show all the stuff they had
to cut out because old [ __ ] looking
Chuck Norris's ass because he did he
didn't want to allow any cut cussing or
anything like that can you imagine like
Chuck Norris on a movie with like a
whole crew and a bunch of other like an
ensemble casts and everything oh well no
one can swear I'd be like [ __ ] YouTube
Jesus Christ yeah who the hell do you
think you are yeah telling other people
how to talk yeah but if you guys have
seen part three and didn't like the
theatrical cut see the director's Cuts
it's a whole different it's a whole
different movie it's a lot better yeah
everybody's saying prisoners is
excellent okay well I'm gonna have to
watch that then because I got fascinated
when I went back through a step I was
like oh I really liked enemy and I
really liked all this other stuff but I
don't think I've seen prisoners not that
I remember anyway yeah we reviewed Dogs
of War we did yeah with Christopher
Walken yeah that was a good thing yeah I
liked it it was a little weird but I
liked it yeah Christopher Walken can't
play a soldier he
well Christopher Walken can only play
Christopher yeah yeah
nothing wrong with that Christopher
Walken's awesome he had a weird way of
delivering that role uh
but it kind of worked yeah because he he
came off as weird
you know like I said he comes off as
weird in everything yeah I think the
dead zone is the most normal I've ever
seen him like he actually played a
somewhat normal person in that but
that's really the only time but that's
why everybody loves Christopher Walken
because he's because he's weird yeah
weird and awkward yeah weird and awkward
mercenary Soldier slash mercenary
and uh he would just get mad on the drop
of a hat and start yelling over nothing
really you know just because he thought
that's the way the line should be read I
guess okay he's got some issues yeah
Danny Rowling said what's tomorrow's a
haunting episode I think we're gonna do
the calling yeah we'll do the call is
that the one we're doing I think it
might be
it's either
these are C it's either season three
episode four or season four episode
three maybe I can't really remember but
it's one of those it's in season three
or season four
um Zach says I also love the bit where
Benicio is beating up the dude in the
interrogation room and you just hear it
happening in the camera zoom zooms in on
the floor drain yeah that's really good
like he just comes in and like [ __ ]
pees on the guy yeah
[Laughter]
before
[Laughter]
I mean every yeah everything about this
movie is good and actually now like now
that we're talking about because we just
watched it last night but now that we're
talking about I kind of want to watch it
again one of these like pretty soon
we'll see the sequel we'll see the
sequel and then like maybe in a month or
two let's go back and like watch the
other one but yeah I gotta re-watch The
Expendables okay I've seen the first
Expendable about three times and I've
seen the only seen the other ones like
once
well yeah oh I gotta get on it it was
kind of a cheesier cheesy but I liked it
you know I mean I mean I mean I thought
the the best of it is inherently cheesy
yeah I thought that's what everybody
liked about yeah it's like a throwback
80s action sure
Danny Rowling said what's the haunting
episode Tom was talking about with the
black slave goes together I thought that
that was or unless I just got confused
and like somebody just told me that
title because I asked I was like oh what
episode is that and somebody said it was
the calling and I was like well now I
don't remember if it is or not but
whatever
uh so I think that I thought that one
was later on
if we discover that it's a different one
I think it might be season six or seven
if we discover that's a different one
we'll either do the calling tomorrow or
we'll find that one and watch it but
I'll post tomorrow like in the community
tab like on YouTube and like what it'll
be tell you what it'll be like before we
do it
um so there's that because I'm not
entirely sure that it's that one I
thought that it was but I could very
well be missing yeah yeah they're in
there too yeah this is my house yeah it
might have been the calling but the
thing is they all sound the same that's
what I mean it's like it's really really
difficult to know because I'll find it
all of the names sound the same I have
it yeah we have it because we've seen it
before I just don't remember what it's
called yeah so if it's not that one then
we'll watch that one and then I'll post
in the and I'll post tomorrow like which
one it is like in the morning so
everybody will know and you'll have time
to like watch it before we go on all
right so that is are we are we done yeah
yeah okay all right so uh remember to
tune in tomorrow uh at 6 p.m Eastern
Standard time for our haunting Mondays
we'll have a drink and talk about an
episode of a haunting and so that should
be really really fun uh thanks everybody
for dropping by and have a good rest of
your weekend we'll see you guys again
tomorrow bye